allô allô comment ça va
aujourd'hui à ollumi on va parler de la
relocalisation des inouïes en français
la déportation la réinstallation des
Inuits
c'est vraiment un sujet important pour
moi c'est vraiment intense par contre
j'aime mieux vous expliquer en avant ce
que c'est un sujet
qu'on commence à parler
entre nous entre inouïe
c'est pas ma famille qui m'a expliqué ça
donc c'est encore nouveau je me suis
appuyé par certains textes que j'ai vu
en ligne et j'ai aussi fait partie de NS
nous n'avons si vous nique sa voûte à
Ottawa pour apprendre sur les Inuits
pour les inouïdes pour apprendre sur la
culture notre histoire
pleins de sujets importants puis on a
aussi écouté un documentaire qui se
nomme one day in the life of now
en anglais mais ça peut pas être vous
permettre de voir un petit visuel de
qu'est-ce que je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
la délocalisation des Inuits ça s'est
fait dans les années 50 avec la GRC la
Gendarmerie royale du Canada on ne
déplacé
92 inouïe de inujah
jusqu'au nous n'avons
le gouvernement du Canada comme ordonné
tout ça
pour obtenir la citoyenneté canadienne
dans
l'extrême article
et tout ça en proposant une condition de
vie incroyable en disant aux Inuits que
la faune était abondante qui allait
vraiment vivre bien
mais tout ça était des faux espoirs on a
beaucoup menti dans tout ça envers les
Inuits on avait comme pas le choix en
fait on est venu à inaudio
forcer on nous a expliqué qu'est-ce
qu'il y a à l'arrivée à peu près mais
les Inuits il y avait pas l'option de
dire non
donc on a amené les Inuits certaines
familles
dans un bateau puis on est parti
dans le Grand Nord
les familles ont été séparées
et installés dans des communautés
on a dit aux ennuis que tout allait bien
se passer parce que dans deux ans
style correct allait revenir à une joie
malheureusement c'est pas qu'est-ce qui
est arrivé
le Grand Nord était vraiment difficile
pour les familles inouïes j'ai commencé
à avoir comme une certaine dépression
aussi
faisait du noir froid c'était difficile
de trouver la nourriture
c'était vraiment dur de s'adapter au
territoire
il y a aussi la GRC qui a commencé à
s'installer dans les communautés donc il
y avait beaucoup de voyages de
va-et-vient beaucoup de marchandises
mais la marchandise était seulement
utilisée pour la GRC et les Inuits
chercher la nourriture on va dire voler
la nourriture aux gens de la GRC c'était
vraiment mal vu
je vous dis ça parce que souvent on a
comme rabaisser les Inuits on les a
jamais aidés
même que la première année que les
Inuits étaient dans le grand article
dans le Grand Nord
les Inuits ne pouvaient pas construire
du
c'était pas propice à faire des igloos
donc il vivait dans des temps
beaucoup trop froid pour eux
surtout venant du navet où est-ce que
les conditions étaient plus agréables
plus faciles
il y a aussi une dans ces années-là
quelques années plus tard la tuberculose
donc ça fait en sorte que beaucoup de
communautés beaucoup de inouïe qui ont
discuté pour se rendre dans le sud du
Canada
donc c'est encore plus déchirant encore
plus de séparation entre les familles
pourquoi ça nous impacte encore
aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a eu un moment où est-ce
que on a dû travailler énormément il y a
des gens qui travaillaient même pour
pouvoir payer un voyage un vol pour
retourner à inujah ça a pris des années
des années il y en a qui se sont adaptés
avec force puis on a aussi que il fait
pas retourner dans leur communauté parce
qu'il était rendu éloigné de leur
famille
mais tout ça a eu des impacts sur notre
culture sur l'apprentissage de notre
culture pour les prochaines générations
ça l'a amené des trauma
intergénérationnels ça a le rester en
nous
ça le restait des générations en général
mais moi en ce moment c'est quelque
chose que je parle pas avec ma famille
on a encore cette mentalité là de
travailler
c'est un peu difficile il y a eu un
moment donné un moment où est-ce qu'on a
voulu faire une réparation
je pense que les excuses étaient
nécessaires
mais en même temps il y a encore plus à
faire on parle de
situation où est-ce que c'est difficile
d'avoir accès à de la nourriture encore
aujourd'hui c'est excessivement cher on
a la difficulté avec les logements juste
la condition de vie des Inuits aussi et
vraiment difficile dans le fond il y
avait plein d'objectifs on crée des
trucs entre eux le gouvernement
sans
demander aux ennemis
en ayant aucun représentant inouïe tous
ces décisions là ont été faites à Ottawa
puis il y avait aucun mini qui était
présent donc tout ça prouve que on doit
continuer à nous écouter écouter notre
voix
on connaît notre territoire le mieux
je suis fière de dire qu'aujourd'hui on
a des leaders des gens
qui ont utilisé leur voix au sein du
gouvernement qui sont inouï maintenant
c'est important d'avoir notre
perspective notre réalité
inclut dans les décisions
je vais finir
cette chronique là ça a été vraiment
difficile pour moi de mettre des mots
c'est beaucoup de dates de notre
territoire de non personne j'ai
probablement oublié des choses aussi des
points importants mais je pense que vous
avez un peu compris
ce qui est arrivé aux inouïdes du
Nunavut qui venait du Nord du Québec
c'est important ça fait partie de notre
histoire c'est vrai que c'est pas
vraiment enseigné non plus ça me fait
plaisir de vous partager ça merci
d'avoir été là avec moi dans cette
aventure que je continue aussi à
apprendre de vivre ça comme ça c'est
vraiment apaisant pour moi parce que ça
répond à beaucoup de questions
que moi-même j'avais donc passez une
belle journée